this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday the 16th of may the joint is
brought to you by one of my favorites
freeze pipe listen no matter how hot it
gets outside keep your [__] bong ice
cold with freeze pipe let me tell you
how it works
the pipe comes with a detachable chamber
you freeze beforehand
and when you're ready to [__] see the
devil
you fill up that [__] little bong hit
and the hot smoke passes through the
frozen part cooling down the smoke as
you inhale [__] tremendous
just like my days back in colorado 83
your smoke will be so cold you think
you're blowing frosty the snowman listen
i love this [__] pipe you understand
me i love the bong i love the pipe i
love everything that they're doing over
there so it's a bong pipe or bubbler
freeze pipe the freezepipe.com
has the answer for you i love this
[__] company i love these bongs i
love the the little
what the [__] is it called again the
bubbler oh my god and my pipe broke
jimmy [__] schubert dropped it
so
we called and they're sending a new tube
for me that's how strong
the freeze pipe is stop [__] around
if you want to see the devil and you
want big hits of smoke freeze pipe is
the way to do it it's non-toxic it
freezes faster than water and it stays
frozen
longer freeze pipe cools down the smoke
by hundreds of [__] degrees and you
get stoned and see the devil like a
[__] soldier so do me a favor
to the joint family the
thefreezepipe.com
go to thefreezepipe.com
press and code joey and i'm going to
save you 10
on your first order trust me you're
going to be very happy with this [__]
thing
you get a bung you get a pipe or you get
a bubble you get all three who the [__]
am i to tell you what to do this ain't
communist cuba so do me a favor that's
the freezepipe.com
press and code joey save 10
and get ready to see the devil the right
[__] way if you could smoke
from it freeze pipe makes it
the joint is also brought to you by
on it listen i've been with honest since
my [__] beauty in the beast days
i love it
the [__] shroom tech sport the shroom
tech immune tremendous the [__]
alpha brain the new black label listen
to me
i'm cooking with [__] gash if you
guys hear it it's because ana put it
together honor is number one
when it comes to supplements like i told
you i'm going back with the club bats to
help my shoulders anik got those too but
i can't help you with club bats or
kettlebells supplements is where i got
you whether you want the [__] alpha
brain powder
the shroom tech powder the the jerky
listen go to honor.com look at the fine
selection of supplements they have when
you find something you like press in
church joey a joint and get 10 off
delivered right to your [__]
house freeze piping on it that's the way
to go let's get this podcast started tip
top [__] magoo
hey how you doing
come on
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
yes it is it's monday
the 16th of [__] may
before i even start talking [__] i want
to let
the residents and my favorite [__]
city
buffalo know i got your [__]
back uh my heart goes out to the
families that [__] neighborhood
which uh
you know apparently that was the only
supermarket in the neighborhood and
already this morning if you guys want to
help out josh potter great comedian out
of buffalo
posted a uh a link to just send
groceries guys this ain't gonna set you
back two thousand dollars i just sent
like 40. you then mow it to be flow
community fridge
venmo 20 bucks 10 5 to b flow
community fridge they're going to
deliver food you know milk eggs pampers
[__] like that you know i i went back
and forth with josh potter i called my
other brother steve
chevonne that's my first buffalo brother
i met steve chavani in 19 [__]
85 84 in aspen and uh
you know at the time i was dating a girl
from buffalo you know people always say
how come you like buffalo so much
because i was exposed to buffalo early
on the second reason i love buffalo so
much is the heart that these [__]
people have you know over the last 30
years if you don't know the history
everybody pulled out of that fisher
price all these big companies left
buffalo on a [__] lurch
and uh you know
rick james died i mean buffalo's been
sad since rick james died i've been
[__] sad since rick james died but on
the [__] up and up buffalo's a great
city man
if it wasn't for buffalo i would not
be doing comedy if you really [__]
think of that that's why everybody wants
to know why my loyalties to buffalo why
i don't touch [__] ranch dressing
with my wings why i don't allow it on my
[__] table
because if it wasn't for buffalo i would
not get on that microphone a kid from
buffalo
said he would kill me if i didn't get on
stage when he came out of jail this
wasn't some [__] jerk off this guy
had killed his wife and the mailman so i
know he didn't give a [__] about me
so he looked me straight in the eye and
he's like hey man i've never talked any
i mean i had a relationship with the guy
for like eight months i would see him
every day for after breakfast i'd read
newspapers in the prison [__] library
and we'd talk about sports and [__] this
[__] was a genius
and each would talk to me from time to
time
those eight months in that [__] jail
or wherever the [__] i was at let me
tell you something man my spirits never
went down never had a chance to go down
because i was surrounded with buffalo
people t i mean there was so many
[__] in prison colorado from
buffalo and they reminded me of who the
[__] i was when i got in there
buffalo people are all heart
and [__] balls that's why you come to
my table at ranch i gotta ask you to
leave because
the tradition i mean and comedy up there
is a different [__] level
when you go up there it's a mix between
buffalo savages and canada savages and i
don't know if you've ever gone done
comedy in front of canada's [__]
savages they do not [__] around they
they come over that bridge you know the
way mexicans sneak over
they sneak over that [__] bridge to
buffalo to laugh have a good [__]
time you know so
i don't want to
bust out over this but hey man my heart
goes out to you [__] and
you know i'm going to look at other
things we could [__] help out with
the patreon but this was one thing i had
to do today
was just benbow b flow
community
fridge and they'll drop off eggs milk
[__] like that because this is the only
supermarket in that [__] area
so uh with that said yeah
uh i don't know how much long in the
last year two of my favorite [__]
cities in the world
had shootouts boulder
last year at this now
maybe like a year and a half ago didn't
something happen in boulder supermarket
the supermarket i used to shoplift
[__] uh
seafood kebabs from me and georgie we
used to go in there i mean it was a
great supermarket it was a great [__]
neighborhood
south boulder when i saw that that
[__] guy went into boulder i was like
there's the beginning of the end nothing
happens in boulder
nothing happens involved this is why
when they kill john renee ramsey it was
all over the [__] place
because nothing happens in [__]
boulder
sorry guys i went for a nice long walk
today
a little fit soda never hurt nobody
chris camosi called me up he's like
thank you
it's great i love this and he's gonna
send me some [__] root beer float
and uh cherry uh vanilla [__] flavor
but you know like i was talking to my
brother steve this morning i called him
up just to you know he's a buffalo dude
i asked him where he was because he's
like one of those
snow birds he goes to florida after year
and he goes to buffalo and he happened
to be a [__] buffalo and uh
you know i asked him how's the [__]
town and [__] he goes the only thing
that they're really happy about
is that the guy wasn't from buffalo he
was from out of buffalo maybe 40 minutes
away an hour away
because if it would have been a buffalo
resident they would have really [__]
been sad so
again i don't want to keep harping on
this [__] i feel bad for that white dude
because he shot 11 black people and he
shot two white dudes and i'll tell you
what
buffalo brothers don't [__] around so
he's on protective protective protective
custody in that jail buffalo's got a lot
of tough brothers bro
buffalo does not [__] around and uh i
feel for that [__] guy but who gives
a [__] anyway let him get raped in jail
what are we talking about here
you [__] up your [__] diet scope like
someone some other guy was saying well
you know
guys we're living in a world right now
we're living in a country in america
where
you know crime is up in every [__]
aspect
you know for years people blame guns
like ah
guns guns guns gun dog guys with all
this [__] shooting you need a gun
you need a [__] gun i mean i hate to
[__] say it i know a lot of a lot of
you people are anti-gun and whatever
listen man guns don't kill people people
[__] kill people
obviously there was something touched
you know like i told you a couple for
the last [__] two years i've been
telling you that mental health has taken
over this [__]
world all of a sudden everybody's got a
[__] people are smacking people
[__] you know it's just out of
control and every day you wake up and
you don't
you say to yourself i'm what what am i
going to read today what am i going to
read today about the crime in l.a about
the crime in miami about the crime it's
it's a
the guy on patreon put it best for me he
goes everybody's talking about shortages
of baby milk and diapers and wood the
biggest shortage we have right now is a
shortage of love
for some reason it's just not [__]
it's just not [__] working you know
and you want to think about these things
but you don't
you know what do you do you live in your
[__] house you can't even go to a
supermarket now i mean both these
shootings the last
year at [__] supermarkets can you
imagine that's a saturday morning i just
got off the phone with mike mike what
are we doing nothing get some hot dogs
get some [__] burgers come over stop
at the liquor store you know get some
buns
you know can you imagine just walking
into a supermarket
just to get some [__] hot dogs you
know like what were you doing wrong what
the [__] were you doing wrong he just
went in
you said hello to the clerk
somebody asked you about [__] golf or
whatever the [__] you're like yeah i
don't play whatever
and all of a sudden boom you get shot in
the [__] head how do you explain that
how did how do you explain to yourself
when you're on the [__] floor asking
yourself why did i even come here
what the [__] just happened i just came
in for a [__] because you you
actually get shot and you [__] think
for a few minutes you know what the [__]
happened
so
i don't know i always think about that
[__] i don't know if it's the actor
thing that i learned like the moment
before but i always think about the
moment before like what was what were
these poor people [__] thinking
they were just doing that weekly grocery
shopping i mean
listen
you know me guys
people get shot every [__] day for
stupid reasons
some people deserve it
you know and some people [__] don't
you know
but these
people didn't they just
you know you don't recover from that
you never recover from that
uh this is what we don't hear we hear of
the people that got killed
what about the 30 people that witnessed
that
what do you think where their world is
at right now
it's uh
it's not [__] good these people you
know
or some of my wife there they were
talking about
i was watching something i i don't know
i was watching boardwalk empire
and they were talking about you know
[__]
bootlegging whatever out of anything you
know
and i remember telling my wife's like
yeah you ever taste bootleg yeah it
tastes like [__] gasoline
i tried it one time like what's that
[__] people make
to try to [__] you up it tastes like
[__] horrid
they made it in jail i don't know why
people drink that [__]
moonshine moonshine oh my god but not to
get on the moonshine tip
you know i was telling my wife we're
talking about and went from drugs to
whatever we're talking about boardwalk
empire watching there was no drugs back
then you know
and the conversation came up she said to
me she goes how long have you not done
coke for now and i know it's going to be
15 [__] years i'm happy you brought
it up i'm really proud of that you know
i'm really proud of that and she was
like
what really got to you if you had to
like write a book or
or
uh
go to an a.a meeting and you had to
speak
now looking back
what was
the main thing what do you think the
main thing
that made you quit was i mean did you
really want to quit no
i mean i would have done coke till i was
80 if i could have you know honest
honest i mean you want me to be honest
with you i would have done coke till
they would have found me on the street i
was what you call a [__] junkie okay
but
at the same time i watched that
movie ray whatever the [__] ray charles
movie and
i said that dude did heroin do like 60
something as much as i wanted to do coke
until i was 60 and snort and look out
windows and party and do dirty things
with dirty women
you know i had a life i i
had what i didn't have before i had was
now in front of me i had a [__] life
but if i had a narrow one thing was it
for my career was it for my life it was
for none of those things guys
i never thought i had a [__] career
so i could sit here and say to you yeah
i gave up coke
because i know i didn't i gave up coke
because hey i had to i was getting jolts
in my [__] neck my head felt like it
was going to explode when it wasn't when
i did a line it was after i was settled
like i had done like a gram or two i
would just start [__] twitch and
that's not good
once you get that twitch it's not good
listen it's not good so
but this the main thing that it was it
wasn't career it wasn't
nothing i didn't give a [__] about
anything guys it was i didn't want my
wife
at the time was my girlfriend
to find me
that's it
that's
and i'm gonna tell you why because again
i'm the type of guy i could find you
call the ambulance
run run through your pockets
take your [__] pinky ring off no i'm
just teasing you
i could find you how do i know because i
found my mother and i'm still here i
could find you and
call the ambulance and keep it [__]
together till they leave how do i know i
went through it and then after the body
leaves you go through whatever the [__]
you go through you know
i don't think my wife could have done it
i think it would have affected my wife
the same way
those people at the supermarket
yesterday or in colorado
or anytime you witness anything like
that you feel for a few days you just
feel like everything's been taken away
you feel dirty you know you feel a lot
of things how do i know because i saw a
lot of things in my life but since i was
an animal it didn't affect me
how it would affect normal people i saw
things as a kid i saw like my step dad
shoot a guy you know i just saw a bunch
of fights at the bar and people bleeding
and all that [__] so
i kind of got used to my wife never was
you know she wasn't mike mike's the
sweetheart of a guy
plays the guitar has some [__] kids
doesn't bother anybody if mike found me
on the floor if he came here to do a
podcast and i was still doing coke and
mike farm he wouldn't be the same for 18
two years
and then
every year he'd have like a little
[__] mental breakdown not like he'd
end up in a white jacket or something
but you get quiet for a few days it
really affects who the [__] you are
to witness anything like that a debt
you know you don't even know what
happens to your mind when you witness
[__] like that so that was the reason
why i basically [__] just said you
know what
i got to get off this [__] wagon
because she can't find me
and even if i die and i'm you know she's
got nothing she'll never be the same
person again
she'll probably move on and have another
relationship or whatever but
that'll stay with her for [__] ever
and she'll have to do therapy about it
maybe talk to somebody after a few years
because you never know how to process
that [__] nobody knows how to process
that [__] but now on a [__] light of
no [__] suckers
uh i have not watched the amber heard
[__] johnny depp thing not even for
two minutes
and i did not know what was going on
with
brian callan and and
bobby lee and all these guys i had no
idea guys honest to god for all you guys
that wrote me little [__] side notes
that brendan was a [__] worm and all
this [__] cause me and john bernthal
were talking about him listen guys
i i don't know what's going on i don't
know who hits on who
i don't know what's said up there
anymore like i said
before we even start this conversation
mental health is [__] king so
i don't know what happened i realized
mike kind of told me i know that after i
did the podcast
with
john i thought everything was fine there
was no [__] you know and all of a
sudden two days later people like joey i
think you're wrong about brendan he's a
[__] chooch he's this he's that and i
was like hey guys listen
i know the dude he's a student of comedy
he works hard
i i have not it's like i haven't been
around brendan for 18 months but when
you open up the computer
you see you know when you go on youtube
to get music or whatever there's always
a one brendan this brendan special truly
poppy
brendan this i said i don't even know
what to [__] say anymore i don't even
know you know i watched the special it's
on youtube
i watched like 15 minutes of it it's
brendan
is it [__] hysterical
yeah no
but it's funny he has some great [__]
things it's like any other special i
[__] watch on netflix or any other
[__] thing i mean okay it's
outstanding to [__] like rodney and
all those [__] no
but brendan's doing okay he's trying
like i said i don't know what's going on
i'm hitting on bobby lee's girlfriend
bob lee's girl i don't know any about
that thing all i know is what his
character shows me when i open up he
started thick boy he does a food diary
he [__] started a clothing line he's
[__] trying if you don't like him
don't pay don't buy the shirts
if you don't like it don't but for you
[__] to sit there constantly
constantly
and tear into this i don't even know who
the [__] it is i don't even know what
the [__] it is tears into him constantly
he's not you don't think he knows that
you don't think he's heard that
but you know what i give him credit
because after all the [__] everybody
says
he still shows up
he still shows up how many people would
show up would you show up if you were
[__] brendan
with all the [__] against you still
shows up to the comedy store
he still shows up to all these places
whether he's good or not somebody's
paying 25 to go see him
right or wrong i mean somebody's paying
the [__] money to go see him so what
do you for all these shows that he's
selling out are you people going to see
a [__] what's the chick that died from
the ods at the end it's the singer i
went to rehab no no no whatever [__]
natalie whatever i don't know
what's that chick's name
you know i want to go to rehab
that girl at the end she was selling my
shows people were like oh she passed out
well guess what if she sold 5 000
tickets
4 000 tickets
were people who went to see the train
wreck
do you know that i mean
and it's [__] scary to say that a guy
like me would pay 45 bucks
or 50 bucks or 60 bucks to go there with
my heart oh she's going to be different
she's not going to shoot heroin today
you know she's not going to drink
[__] 18 cocktails she's not going to
do 30x i'll be fine i'm joey diaz i'm
going to go see whatever her [__] what's
her name please because
amy winehouse with a [__] up feet
because you know how she had stinky toes
every time i see his shoes and [__] i'm
like
that [__] got those english stinky
little toes and [__]
i love it a deck doll she could sing but
would i pay 50 bucks to go see a train
wreck
to go cheer for somebody to train right
there
[Music]
some people do that's not what i'm i'm
about i don't even [__] you know
the same people that comment but
years ago years ago one of the
best open mics you'd ever go to
mike when you went to this open mic you
didn't even think it was an open mic
you thought
this was a [__] paid show
i wish
i always say this to people i wish i
would have taped [__]
i wish i would have been one of those
idiots i wish i would have been japanese
and walked around with a camera 20 years
ago like with a blogger or something
guys i would have showed you footage
that would have [__]
made your head blow up houston laptop
had an open mic
that started at seven
and it went till two
classic
but it wasn't
it was like the open mic i had in
seattle it was
all right in seattle we had 15 comics so
out of the fifth
let me just be honest out of the 15
people on the list
six of them
were stand-up comics
three of them
were open mic comics that
were working towards something they were
really working towards something
so what does that give me that that's
nine
so five
it would be me brody josh wolf
tana manu
and gatton let's just say five real
comics that we're getting feature work
maybe a headliner would show up maybe so
you got five six real comics then you
had three guys that had been doing
comedy for two years maybe a year maybe
three years and they're getting there
you know the other six people were
mental health
i'm sure you do your [__] open mic
mic
there's mental health shows up
okay and
you know i mean i hold my open mic
career i listen because you have
a beginning of comedy and you have an
open mic career and then you you move
into like other realms like i'm saying
and feature but you're still a [__]
open mic
so when i moved to seattle i was still a
[__] open miker
and i went i wrote hard every monday you
know i worked hard during the week i
made little notes and then everything
was about monday in seattle the same
thing if i bring a houston comic up here
whether it's sean wessling or slade ham
they'll tell you
in 2000
mondays was everything to those people
mondays was everything
to me in l.a because you had
a freaky monday you had latino night at
the lab factory you had freaky monday at
the improv latino night at the live
factory at the comedy store was just an
open mic so you had three spots you
could [__] run
in
houston monday night was open mic
females comics hot
would go down there and get drunk and
you know the comics want to be funny so
they could pick up the young female
comics it was a [__] beautiful thing
to see
and
but
you guys are now in houston for example
they had seven to two
that's
seven hours
so from seven to eight it was comics
from houston like in the area you know
guys that were working out at uh what's
his name spot
the comedy where ralphie started with
the theater down all that it was across
town you had comics at the last spot and
the last stop they had two clubs in
houston for a long time the last stop
and the last spot
so you had all those comics from the
last spot that weren't allowed to mingle
but at the end of the day houston had a
huge comedy scene it was [__]
brilliant to watch
no comic left on monday
like if you worked the whole week in
houston
thursday you know wednesday to sunday
you didn't [__] leave monday morning
even if you lived in l.a you left monday
night or tuesday morning because the
party monday
was so [__] unbelievable
it was so [__] unbelievable
but
back to what i'm saying about mental
health at these [__] things okay so
let's say uh
one of the guys
a prep guy is opening up like he's been
doing comedy two years
then maybe brody stevens would follow
him and then maybe
tayna would go up or josh wolfe you know
these are all potential feature acts
let me tell you something from number
four to number eight
or number four six and seven because the
guy who wrote the list out was carl
and carl
knew how to space it out he knew the
[__] mental health victims
so what he would do is when the mental
health victims would come in and got
guys
joy why do you call mental health victim
well because one guy used to come on
with a [__] handcuff
just one handcuffed with a suit and when
i left seattle he killed himself he left
a note like he blew himself up or
something he was not good you know and
it's very sad guys it's very these are
people who
are alone they're lonely and they go to
open mics and they they think they're
their comics and god bless them
god bless them i've been doing comedy
for
30 something years i've been involved in
comedy
and i think at the comedy store was the
first time i started getting into with
open mic is because they [__] attack
at the comedy store but in seattle and
all those places i was always very
comedy's a karma business so if you're
going to sit in the back and goof on the
[__] young guys this [__] is not
going to work out for you
so watch because those open microship
from time to time that you'll learn
something
they just had a flash of brilliance
you've been doing comedy seven years and
you're like holy [__]
that dude makes sense from what he was
saying this guy's you know whatever so
you know the open the mental health guys
the guys that went up there and like
there was a guy in seattle
who would just go up then go good
evening
i'm doing an impersonation of a bird
did you like it
then he would go my next impersonation
is me as a chipmunk and he'd go
that's when i seen the guy on tv and he
go do you like it
and people wouldn't know what the [__]
to say guys you don't know what the [__]
to say but let me tell you something
about that as bad as that dude was
bombing he was creating a show
he was creating a kind of experience
like i'm watching him from afar going
this is a weird [__] situation and
i'm looking at the audience okay because
it's at the seattle under listen guys my
opening my career was my favorite part
of doing comedy i looking back now
[__] loved it [__] loved it it
sucks to walk into a room and 400 people
love you it sucks to walk into a comedy
room and 1500 people to theater go crazy
it sucks
that sucks about comedy real comedy is
going out there and convincing those
[__] that you're funny now
these [__] that come to the
open mic they all go to like a [__]
we're not laughing meeting together like
we're not gonna laugh at your jokes me
like 20 of those people go to a meeting
and they buy a ticket then they come to
the thing and people go to open mics
they go there and they sit like this
defense
that's it this is this is your audience
at an open mic so when you walk out
there
and you see this you don't really
[__] want to do [__] you're like god
damn this is going to be work you know
when i come out hey how you doing
[__] people like ah it's joey
that's great i love it i've worked hard
to get to that point
but it sucks
it really sucks look at last year philly
helium
was doing the show on wednesdays
secret headliner
sold out every week
i think that's a brilliant idea they
don't know who the headliner is don't
pay the 20.
it could be a good guy or it could be a
shitty guy
but it's people who want to sit down and
get that different experience they want
to maybe let's go we're not doing
nothing
sit at home and watch ozark again you
know some guy [__] laundry money
hello anyway
you know everybody talks about i gotta
stay in and watch ozark go [__] yourself
you've never even sold a nickelback get
the [__] out of my face you're living
vicariously by these [__] half a [__]
actors get the [__] out of here so
you know that that guy in seattle ended
up killing himself
me and josh laughed about it when we got
here like we didn't laugh about it he
just said you know i could kill him
somewhere like that surprises you he
went up on stage with a [__] uh
with a [__] handcuff and a suit on
there was another guy that would just go
up there and say you know this is my
impersonation of a bird there was
another guy that would just go up there
with a ukulele
i'm in denver there was a guy that would
go up on stage and tape his set and then
come back to me and hit
record i mean first of all this kid was
a
nice kid
tons of money
tons of money for you com young comics
that have tons of money
that want to spend ten thousand on a
promo pack don't do it because if you're
not experienced
this guy
had not only did he have money this
[__] he was like 25 he found
like a 50 year old girl to finance his
comedy career she was buying them
thousand dollar suits for him to get on
stage
he had a promo pack that was second to
none like if you call me and go joey i
don't mean to bother you you're doing a
show here on the third can i get a promo
pack [__]
you're gonna get a [__] you're gonna
get a head shot
and a resume and it's gonna be an old
resume i'm not gonna lie it's not gonna
be updated because i don't give a [__]
about that [__] anymore you saw me on
the tv right that's all you need to know
what what episode or what who gives a
[__]
so
what are we talking about
[Music]
so this [__] would send you a
promo pack that was a box
it was a [__] box and the mail would
come to you like this
you would take it out put it down and
one side would open
and it would have like pictures and a
bunch of lies
about newspaper reviews like he just
said the london post said
brilliant and you know heartwarming the
jersey journal said [__] uh anyway
and he put that on the end and then he
would make these clips at his house
this is 1990 guys 91 when i met this kid
i hung out with this kid from 91 to
about 95 and i really tried to [__]
help him as a comedian one day i got in
this car and he goes you can't talk for
an hour
and i go why not what's going on he goes
i thought it was like a ramadan dude or
one of those [__]
he goes no no no i'm going to listen to
my tape of me fighting hecklers
so it was just a tape of him with his
wife or girlfriend yelling like hey
where'd you learn how to whisper in a
helicopter and all this [__] like just
all these stock
like you know when you go to a comedy
club if you don't go to a [__] improv
or one of those if you're like a
lesser-known comedy club behind a
bowling alley or something like that
you're gonna see comics that
i don't know they talk about [__] like
that you know that's their world of
comedy
i don't even know what the [__] i'm
talking about this is terrible i can't
be smoking dope anymore in the morning i
smoke some of that [__] uh holy [__]
weed sometimes if you put it away that
[__] picks up momentum it's like
an expired vicodin you ever eat an
expired viking dog those [__]
do not [__] around usually two of those
like when somebody says to me they got
some expired [__] at the house give me
10 minutes let me swing by and see what
you got because i know some people who
love expired medications
[Music]
but dog i put away some of that [__]
the white truffle is like 26 27
[Music]
it's okay i put some away the other day
and i found it and it was drier than
[__] you know when that weed gets dry
and the [__] thc comes to the top and
it coats that bud i mean these buds were
terrible looking i [__] zipped it up
and i smoked last night i was doing it
last night because i came down here by
one i could not [__] sleep uh sunday
night and i [__] came down here but i
wanna go what the [__] am i gonna do
so i rolled up a joint of uh
the the white truffle and i put some
heavy duty [__]
what do you call that shakif and that
[__]
but then i found this other weed that me
and my cat smoked last week the london
deliciousness what was that
we smoked something lime something it
was something that came lemons lemon
snickers i found the lemon snickers and
it was dry
brittle dry was hidden behind an old
picture of uncle joey i saw it back
there like what the [__] is this let me
tell you something i cut that
[__] up with a scissor i'd even
put it up in the grinder you know when
it gets that brittle [__] the grinder
you're just gonna take all those
beautiful little [__] glass
i cut that [__]
it had to be
a joint it was a big [__] bazooka
type joint and i put some key from that
[__] and i rolled it up last
night oh my god
i went outside and i smoked that i just
sat outside and looked around i saw some
deer walking around i don't know what i
saw like a possum or a raccoon he wasn't
close to me he was like across the
street huge [__]
and i came inside last night and i ate a
bag of blueberries and a half a bag of
those cherries
i took a [__] this morning it was you
know those shits that you feel like you
got raped
you ever take those shits that you feel
like
it burns like when you get out of the
bathroom two hours later your body feels
all crooked like that's the [__] i took
this morning my body was all crooked
when i walked out of there oh my god
anyway who needs to know about that [__]
back to the open mic what i was trying
to say to you guys an open mic is a
[__] uh
a good open mind like i love to do an
open mic here
like i really love to do it can't be at
a comedy club because i like to have
everything involved i'd like to have
some acoustic some [__] like
somebody who throws cards maybe a
magician that the bird gets stuck like
an apprentice magician dog that's the
funniest thing you'll ever see the birds
get stuck on the light
you know he doesn't connect the ropes
and [__]
oh my god have one of those and like
they used to be the show in vegas years
ago with midgets you know i i forgot the
[__] name
when i first started comedy it was
[__] crazy he was still trying to do
it years ago or whatever i like to do
something like that in an open mic
setting
which is craziness to really prepare
because you need
an audience that will give you some [__]
i'm sorry to say with an open mic
you do need it for the all like in
houston we used to know
every three comics somebody would yell
something
you know and that
listen if it's not mean
if it's not like when we were doing the
open mic the guy yeah if it's kind of
like the guy that used to do the open
mic and say this is my impersonation of
a bird
this is my impersonation
of a flower
one day we just yelled out towards the
end
do an impersonation of a comic
and you could hear the
teachers fractured walked off and never
came back
he probably went through a [__] open
mic at a poetry reading because every
every [__] open mic is different have
you been to a poetry reading open mind
oh boy
it's been a long time i started
i poetry reading open mics holy [__]
guys my [__] first year i did comedy
and listen i don't mean to [__] uh
you know
i don't want to blow my horn here
but it doesn't surprise me that i got as
far as i did in comedy
because in the beginning i did anything
i had to do to get on stage and this is
why i knew when i got here
when i got off the [__] boat and came
back to jersey that i would just wait to
see if i would put my sneakers on on my
own
not be no on my own no money no nothing
i want to see
if i could go hmm i'm not doing anything
tonight this is an eight o'clock spot
let me look over my material and let me
go over that because guys i know me
when i started you have no idea
the places i went to you are not gonna
tell me no
listen you're never gonna tell me no
let's get this [__] straight when
you're in love with something you know
mike and i were talking about
responsibilities
if i had what i had now like if we had
listen if i had mercy when i started
comedy
and my wife we would have lived in a
room this big this would have been our
[__] apartment
that's that's for starters i couldn't
afford anything
and neither could my [__] wife okay
so
you
go to an open mic and you
you give it everything that you got
when i started comedy
you know i used to drive to cheyenne
wyoming
cheyenne wyoming to bomb
and then bomb on the and then drive back
with that bomb because let me tell you
something
you know when you're sitting by yourself
in a car and you're thinking about your
bombing it's something that you want to
do
you want to do it too bad that you
[__] taste it you could taste that
[__] microphone i wanted to do comedy
so bad nothing was going to stop me
so if it was in boulder like i said i
told you guys that story about the
chinese guy
ron that i would show up to his little
[__] restaurant and put him together
i was doing comedy in chinese
restaurants first of all i stole that
idea i didn't steal it i heard that they
were doing comedy in boston
all those boston comics got huge by
doing this
restaurant and once a week on monday
nights was upstairs was a a chinese
restaurant i always thought
that was the coolest thing i ever heard
in my life when on christmas eve there's
a chinese restaurant
in san francisco every year that brings
in a jewish comic
to do comedy on christmas or christmas
eve at a chinese restaurant i i i've
always loved that thing about a chinese
restaurant so
you know i used to go to ron and
you know i asked every chinese
restaurant in boulder but when i
delivered that didn't have a stage but
ron had an outdoor area where you could
do [__] stand-up comedy
you know i used to go to
cheyenne wyoming i used to go to
cheyenne wyoming for lunch
it's an hour and a half drive to get
shrimp and lobster sauce and then i
would sit there the rest of the day to
do bobby whatever's room some comic up
that's still around i see i still think
he has the room up in loveland colorado
bobby blatz i forget what his [__]
name was you know
but i think the most painful thing i had
to do was go to a poetry reading i used
to go to poetry readings i think uh
wednesday nights
and saturday nights because saturday
nights no comedy club is going to put
you up for a guest spot you're just
sitting there unless you have your own
thing going on unless you're working
nobody wants to see an open mic on a
saturday night you know so you're dead
when you first start comedy or anything
like that nobody's going to give you
love on the weekend so
you get yourself a job [__] ubering
uh for me it was delivering chinese food
selling coke delivering [__] domino's
pizza whatever the [__] i could do
but
i would shoot after i delivered domino's
pizza i would shoot over the penny lane
coffee house
[__] love that place in boulder and
it was you know a bunch of [__]
hippies a bunch of them want to be you
know woodstockers and [__]
and i would go in there and i the thing
i remember the most
was maybe my second
comedy
the time i went to open poetry reading
there was a dude up there
and he was doing what's that when you
just talk
you just talk about [__] like you know
uh
they call it something it's it's
it's an art now talking like when you
talk story it's not storytelling
it was poetry reading it was poetry
night so it was kind of a poem but
anyway this [__] stayed up there
for like 15 20 minutes
talking about that he ran and he ran and
he ran and he ran and he ran he saw
mountains and hills and he keeps talking
about iran and i was with a guide i was
in the halfway house with in fact that's
how i would get the spots at the poetry
reading he was like an old geezer he was
like my age now
and he was a bank robber but he was
dating a hot little [__] girl that
was a sweetheart
she ran the coffee shop so she told me
she goes they don't want you to come in
here and do comedy but i'll let you in
at night this [__] went up and
he's like i ran i ran
i kept running through the marsh and all
this [__] me and my buddy like what the
[__] is he talking about so when she
goes joe you're up next i just went up
there and mimicked the [__] guy so i
ran and i ran i ran i hit a [__] tree
with my head i didn't know what i said
and then i get the [__] out of here so i
would do that [__] and then they had an
open mic that was
all night they had a
[__] uh
poetry reading that was until six in the
morning
come on guys people come in there and
start like with their [__] and they
smoke those
weird cigarettes clothes
clothes and [__] oh drinking coffee
and i would go down there man and they'd
chase me the [__] out of there but i
didn't give a [__] that would i would
wait i'd actually go home and put it on
my calendar all right so i got there
sunday the 15th and they throw me out i
can't go back there till sunday the 29th
and then i would go back down to 29th i
used to do an open mic after a [__]
what's that [__] achy breaky
heart line dancing class think about
that [__]
i used to and people used to go how do
you go down there they were all rednecks
i don't give a [__] i gotta get stay
time
and i would basically go there to bomb
bomb
it was a number
you know sales and comedy a lot of like
it's a numbers game
you could lose your [__] mind for
years or you could get a pen
go out a piece of paper and write ten
thousand sets backwards
and just start going nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine eight you know for comedy
you're gonna have to do 10 000 spots
just to get somebody's [__] name
think about if you do 30 spots a month
which
that's a day off or two sets for 15 days
right
times
12 is 360 spots
if you did that for 10 [__] years 360
spots
for [__] uh 10 years all right
let's just make it safe
let's pretend
you [__] uh i gotta get a calculator
i don't even know what my [__]
calculator is here that's how stupid i
am so this isn't easy but i just want to
make sure that
i don't want to [__] you guys over so if
you did 360 spots and that's if you
didn't get hurt
that's if your girlfriend didn't dump
you that's if your mother didn't die
that's if your dog didn't get hit by a
car
that's got to be [__] perfect 30
spots a month
it's 360. at 10 years
360 spots
time [__] 10 years
is still 3 600 spots
that's nowhere near 10 000 so all right
let's be fair you got to do 3 600 spots
before you even call my [__] number
i have that for you but no that's and
that's what people need to know when
people are not selling
you know my buddy works at the subaru
dealer where i bought the subaru we
became friends after i bought the subaru
whenever i'm free old i stop in i say
hello i look at the car you know i'm
killing time i gotta i gotta go freehold
for therapy sometimes with my leg
but even him he was telling me one day
he hadn't sold a corner you gotta get it
just gotta get out there and talk to
people
that's it talk to everybody
talk to the lady who goes into [__]
service
talk to the guy who comes in with a red
ugly truck
talk to all those people and after a
while it's just a [__] numbers game
this is the numbers games guys i could
sit here and tell you you have to be
born with a special gift there's no
[__] gift you got to put the time in
that's it
and consistent see and enthusiastically
you know right now i i like doing comedy
i don't want to do it every [__]
night
i don't even know what to do i don't
like going to the city but i'm not
driving two hours a [__] day
but 30 years ago i would drive into the
city twice
i'd probably drive over in the afternoon
just to [__] do an afternoon spot
come home work pick somebody up at the
airport when i was driving limos and i
go back over there
guys this is a work based [__]
business sales
comedy but
you could do it you know why because
it's repetitious and it's a numbers game
it's a [__] numbers game
so the more you [__] do it the better
you get at it you know i see all these
people every time i go online you know
uh i started swinging club battles again
a little bit you know alberto crane
taught me when i was in l.a
and since i can't do kettlebells with my
knee and [__] i've just been doing
the club bells and i don't even know why
i brought this up what was i talking
about that i brought the club bells up i
don't even [__] know
but it's so weird that whenever i go on
uh
youtube i went on last night to look at
uh you know
club belt swings like the accurate way
to do it alberto sent me a few tapes and
he pointed me at scott sonnen who does
some
uh not kettlebell swims those [__]
bat swings and [__]
and it's so weird it's all a [__]
numbers game guys
you know
i could say that yeah listen like for
brendan shaw for example
he's a fighter and i'll tell you
something he crossed over to become uh a
comic
podcaster or whatever
you know what man
i will support brendan
to whatever because he does the job i
have not yet to hear a thing that
brendan stole a joke
um i have not heard anything that you
know whatever brendan does with his side
with women that's his business i'm not
even talking about that
brendan has always gotten my respect
because he's never been afraid of the
oven
you know man you got to hold your feet
to the [__] fire uh and he's been
doing it and whether you like him or not
listen
he's gonna keep working the more you
guys push him and keep saying stupid
[__] about him he's gonna keep working
and it might take him 10 more [__]
years
but he's going to put it together he's
going to prove people wrong if he sticks
it out and it was the same thing i did
guys
you know when i got to l.a i was getting
tortured i'm too dirty i'm too [__]
old i'm too fat i'm too listen
you're not focusing on the main thing
it's too [__] funny so go [__]
yourself with all that other [__]
and guess what the reason i'm tight with
joe after all these years and i'm tight
with bert and tom
because they know i never [__]
skipped a [__] beat
i did everything that was needed to be
done
not once but twice [__] i had two
horrible three horrible specials who
gives a [__] about that when i'm up
there [__] live i will rock your
[__] world but that just didn't
happen guys i just didn't do that i had
a sweat i had a [__] cry
i had to go out there you know
i had to be i just heard something you
know i heard this a couple years ago
get comfortable being uncomfortable
that's it
you want to succeed in life
you got to do the things that you don't
want to [__] do
and i did them even though i didn't want
to [__] do them i i [__] did them
you know i didn't want to work on a
sunday but i had to stay i i wanted to
go to mike's wedding but i had a [__]
show you know
mike and i were talking about
responsibility you know we got here
today about how
mike can't go to see me with joe on the
third and fourth he's got a wife he's
got [__] kids you know and that's
something that nobody prepares you for
i have friends that call me now
and they're like hey man and they're
younger than me and god bless them i
love them they think about me but
they're like hey man what are you doing
right now let's hook up and let's go
and i'm like guys
i'm in the middle of a softball game
i'm in the middle of
a kid's birthday party i'm in the middle
of
you know i just can't get up and leave
don't get me wrong
i love to do what you're doing instead
of being here but this is where i need
to be
that's where i want to be this is where
i need to be it's two different [__]
stories and that's what makes you a
better version of you guys honest to god
you know anybody could do like i just
told you guys you know
i love doing comedy
but i gotta be honest it was ari brought
up to me years ago and that's why my
netflix special
wasn't as good as i wanted it to be
because
i didn't
perform at the comedy store before that
netflix special for some reason me and
ari were talking about how you go into
these audiences
that are there to see you
and that
you can't do anything wrong in front of
them so you don't know what you're doing
wrong
so because of that i was like [__] it
he's got a point i won't put my name on
any list
and i'll go to places
like i was going to flappers i was going
uh
the fourth wall which i really didn't
belong in at that time but i went it was
a the fourth wall is an open mic place
in l.a a lot of young comics hanging
there i enjoyed myself going there like
people would ask me different questions
young comics would ask me questions it
was great to help somebody out but i
didn't belong there
but i thought
what what ari said and him and i were
talking i was like yeah you got a point
there
so i'll go to all these rooms that don't
know i'm coming well you know they knew
i was [__] coming because somebody
let them know anyway but the point is
i didn't do what was comfortable
and i and that was all the way up to the
end in 2016 when i didn't have to do a
[__] special people were coming to
the shows i was doing great on set on
stage i had a [__] hour i always had
a new hour
but you have to do that
to grow from time to time and it's like
now i got two weeks to [__] show time
with rogan
i got about 25 [__] minutes on paper
which means i got
18 on stage right if you got 25 and to
be honest i'm kind of scared
because 25 on paper for a regular comic
would be 20.
i speak so [__] fast and i blow
through it
and my energy level
then i got to do it 15. you know right
now i'm preparing for that i'm two weeks
away and i'm preparing for it like a
little kid i'm excited
uh thursday i'm going with uh jimmy down
to uncle vinnie's
to do a benefit for one of the kids in
the marlborough sports section so i'm
gonna go get a sitting there i'm
thinking i'm going into the city maybe
tuesday night i spoke to somebody all i
need is just a couple of sets to warm up
the [__] rogan and i'll be ready the
most important i mean
the physical performance is that it's
the
material and my confidence and material
and how i put it out so i i made a
couple nice little jokes this weekend
i don't even know if they're nice little
jokes they just
and i'm not being uh i'll tell you what
man i don't wanna
i'm going for it guys
when i'm up there i'm doing short sets
like i'm doing the 20 minutes with bert
i'm doing the 15 i and i did that for a
reason
i don't think i could i think i lost a
step as a comic we all do i haven't been
in that [__] realm of you know the
comedy store in two [__] years that's
uh you're in the major leagues pal you
know you're i was in the major leagues
for 23 [__] years i stepped out of
the major leagues
now i got a great time comedy in new
york if i want to attack it i got a
great comedy scene here but now i'm busy
i'm getting old all i got to do you know
i enjoyed with gay i never saw gabriel
in l.a unless he did the podcast
or somebody told me he was going to ha
ha you know many times he saying kevin
hart in l.a
zero
because those [__] do their
best writing when they're on the road
they really do i really gotta hand it to
them they do great writing on the road
when they're in town they don't work out
they don't want to know about working
out they don't want to talk about
working out so
so monday mornings podcasts we're going
to end with this guys
you want to grow as a [__] human
being
do what you don't want to do to get to
that [__] goal
all those things that you think suck
that's what needs to be done
you know it's funny with comedy i'm the
first [__] to complain i really
am i'm the first guy that's looking for
a complaint but was when i was on my
road when i was on my [__] mission
for gold
i didn't complain i just went in that
way think i did [__] these great
venues when i was [__] no
you know when you're going into a great
venue like atlantic city the stress
factory uncle vinnie's new york comedy
club caroline's when you go up to these
great venues you get fired the [__] up
you get fired the [__] up you're like
[__]
i never thought i would be at [__]
caroline's i got to show these
[__] who the [__] i am so
that's part of it but when you're
playing snake river
south dakota where the [__] it is how
excited are you
you know you thought you were going to
be on the jerry lewis telethon hanging
out with [__]
celebrities and here you are in snake
river
[__] talking to a mexican waiter in
the back because he's the only guy that
speaks spanish in the next 10 [__]
miles well i got some coke from some
weeds so he cut the [__] thing but
you guys know what i mean it's
it's uh
it's a long way to the top if you want
to rock and roll
ac dc said it best
i love you [__] with all my
heart it's monday morning i got [__] to
do and people to [__] see i'm
happy because i could finally announce
that i'm going to be somewhere thursday
the 19th
i'll be with uh jimmy florentine down in
the uncle vinnie's i think there's like
30 tickets left there's no i'm only
gonna do like 15 minutes just to warm
myself up and if you want to come out on
thursday night
and uh have a good time come on down and
help some people with a good cause come
on down go to uncle vinnie's right now
and take a look at uncle vinnies.com i
think in point plus and then take a look
and buy a [__] ticket you're helping
out
some kids and whatnot and that's it and
that's that [__] it's monday
morning i got no [__] uh
i got no uh
beef for you guys i don't know
i'm happy that
brendan's happy i'm happy that amber
heard's happy you know somebody some
idiot [__] hit me up the other day
and said do you think as a professional
do you think amber heard was really
snorting coke up on stage
why would happen i don't know it was
just a video for her i've heard with a
tissue yeah
listen
or guys
it's weird
dog listen i've done some coke in some
weird [__] places but i've never done
a judge's [__] chamber if that [__]
did coke and a judge's chamber sign her
up she'll let you light her [__] on
fire that crazy [__] and just from what
i've heard
guys it's not good it's so weird how
some guy and i'm trying to
tell you guys with the john bernthal
podcast
i wanted to talk to him about it maybe
i'll bring it up next week i got a guy
coming on here you guys gonna love but
you know i read an article after the
amber heard thing and the chris rock
thing
guy at new york times it was pretty
interesting because i think the same way
guys when i was coming up
i thought charles bronson was a god i
thought steve mcqueen was a god i
thought
ava gardner was a god i thought all
these actors that i saw
were these big [__] people clint
eastwood they were just big you know
i love richard gere i saw richard gear
one night and i didn't go up to him i
didn't say hello i didn't [__] want
to take a picture with no pictures then
there was no [__] like no nobody had
a phone that came my point is
the reason why i didn't go up to richard
gere that night was because
i'm a piece of [__]
i'm a [__] guy from jersey what do i
know about that [__] world these guys
were born with [__] gold spoons in
that pocket or so i thought
but
when you look at a celebrity
mom brando [__]
the chick that you sang out with michael
jackson with the monkeys what was the
name the elizabeth taylor you know diana
ross
these people are [__] huge icons you
know at least they were to me when i
look at julius irving as a basketball
player they meant the world to me guys
larry bird meant the [__] world to me
i kept telling my mom i want to move to
french lick indiana i want to move to
front you know it doesn't [__] matter
you're not the idiot that i was
i thought they were everything to me
the last couple years because of what's
going on
with social media
they're not big anymore
when
amber heard took the stand against
johnny depp well i shouldn't keep saying
amber and when johnny depp
this whole thing that came through what
this guy said on this article he wrote
which is pretty brilliant he said that
it was the end of the celebrity
and it really is celebrities come a dime
a dozen now
they come a dime a [__] dozen
you could contact them
they could do a [__] bubble picture
for you call those things they could
send the cameo to you you know
you could reach them
you know and i like that this has become
this way
it's it's great
but i want you guys to know
that this wasn't the way it always was
a celebrity was something that was so
far from you
it was so far from you that you couldn't
even imagine
in your mind they were so much better
than you and they're really not they all
put their pants on one at a time you
learn that when you know you're 20 18
19. this guy gets sucked my dick he puts
his pants one leg at a time but they
were so big now they're nothing
like now they're nothing i never
considered myself a celebrity i hate the
[__] thought of it i'm an r-rated
comic i'm not a celebrity i'll never do
one of those vh1 things that's not my
bag i'm a dirty comic i went to jail and
that's it i got some movies take it do
what you want with it there's nothing
spectacular here there's no talent here
i can't do a magic trick i can't save a
life i can't do nothing
so i don't consider myself these [__]
things
the only thing i got for you people with
my balls in my heart and my lessons on
how to [__] stick it out with these
jerk-offs and let them know they ain't
[__] but
now you could contact the celebrity you
could talk to them
you could attack them on stage you could
[__]
smack them on stage it's like
they had nothing they'd become nothing
but we've lowered the bar as
as americans like we've lo like really
like all these people like they you
really care about this dude like
this dude don't care about you
like when i see all these young girls i
try to be kim kardashian it's like you
guys have no idea did you see what came
out that the mother pimped her out with
rj you know guys it's la it's disgust
you have nothing to do with that that's
a disgusting life you imagine your
mother was behind your [__] porn tape
are you [__] seriously
but that's and this is the [__] that you
people watch and think it's acceptable
and stuff even me i'm a [__] pig you
can't put a silk hat on a [__] pig
but i'm not here trying to tell you how
to run your life i'm just here telling
you you could do it whatever the [__]
you want to do whatever you think is far
away from you that you can't maintain
like when i was a kid and i see those
celebrities and go i could never be in a
movie
[__] you
you could do whatever the [__] you want
especially now they ain't [__]
so strap on a [__] bear and get your
thinking up it's over there's no more
there's nobody better than you all these
[__] these sports athletes look
at the [__] they're doing half the
[__] time they ain't better than you
you guys think you're missing something
oh i'm not hanging out with jason momoa
who gives a [__] that guy can't do an
algebra [__] problem tell them what
to do come on guys
get your [__] together these [__]
people
this is where you spend your time you
want this entertainment this
entertainment guys this ain't no big
[__] deal i can't do nothing i can't
do a magic trick i can't cook a pot
roast who the [__] is this [__] you know
what i'm saying at least i'm honest i
love you [__] have a great
week stay black and don't take no [__]
from nobody and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors jack
all right i want to thank you
[__] i want to thank amber
heard i want to thank everybody who
we talked about on the podcast today
sick [__] i love you but anyway
before we go
the joint is brought to you by freeze
pipe i talked about this in the
beginning of the [__] show
the freeze pipe is the best little
bubbler i've ever had in my life you
don't know what i'm talking about here's
how it works this pipe bomb bubbler
comes with detachable chamber that you
freeze beforehand when you're ready to
[__] smoke it you go in the freezer
you defrost the steak and you take out
the frozen part it cools down the smoke
as you inhale
the smoke will be so [__] cold uh
unbelievable how good it it just goes
right in zip you don't even feel it i
love it i got a bubbler
and i'll tell you what i got a bung i'm
in love with the bubble i just fill it
up i take three [__] whacks of that
thing and i'm ready to [__] go i
could see 3d so do me a favor go to the
freeze pipe right now pressing code joey
and i'm going to get you 10
off your first [__] order with the
freezepipe.com
joey again
thefreezepipe.com
joey the joint is also brought to you by
on it listen i've been with them for
close to 12 [__] years
i loved on it all their supplements
alpha brain shroom tech
shroom tech sport
the [__] protein bars are tremendous
go to honor.com right now
read
learn the jerky the protein powder
mexican chocolate [__] tremendous go
to honor.com preston joey church or
joint and get 10 percent off delivered
right to your [__] house tip
top my goal i want to thank freeze pipe
i want to thank honest but most
importantly i want to thank you
[__] for always having my back
stay black
have a great week and i'll see you
[__] wednesday tip top magoo
love ya
[Music]
you